chaque année les [ __ ] se réunissent
pour la bonne cause dans le cas d'une
série de concerts au profit des restos
du coeur une opération solidaire lancée
par coluche en 1985 et qui ces dernières
années aurait connu un petit changement
d'ambiance
cette fois ci c'est hélène ségara qui a
décidé de prendre la parole pour
balancer celle qui a quitté la troupe il
ya six ans déjà
n'a pas hésité à évoquer l'ambiance
parfois pesante qui règne au sein du
groupe
je n'ai jamais fait de caprice je me
suis adapté aux costumes que les autres
voulaient bien laisser aux chansons que
les autres ne voulaient pas au profit de
paix de personnes qui étaient plus
exigeantes pierre palmade lui aussi
avait dénoncé ces égos qui font du mal à
la cause je m'amuse mois dans les loges
voilà ça c'est important jean-michel
main sur sun même son cloche du côté de
muriel robin ou encore jean marie bigard
qui ont tous quitté la troupe pour des
raisons similaires
alors qu'a pris ces révélations pensez
vous qu'il y ait une mauvaise ambiance
au sein des [ __ ] en france une radio
que j'adore la chanson française j'adore
et love alors les [ __ ]
y at il une mauvaise ambiance au sein
des enfants c'est que vous avez des
infos nicolas pernikoff annoncé
clairement il ya une vraie ambiance on
entend parler depuis une dizaine
d'années récemment n'est ni coluche
michalak d'allemagne avait un meneur as
hélène ségara qui est plutôt une belle
personne et une gentille c'est une très
bonne chose
je pense qu'effectivement il a présenté
pour une conne parce qu'elle est sympa
que à un moment donné elle accepte de
prendre la chanson qui reste elle finit
par prendre le costume qui restent et
qu'elle en a un peu ras le bol de
toujours comme quand je vous dis on je
vous donnais je vous dis une anecdote
dans les [ __ ]
un jour il ya tous les artistes qui sont
venus voir hélène ségara voulait quitter
la troupe et l'on dit il ya trop de gens
qui t'aiment
oui parce qu'on a guy lux cas des infos
les infos sur le fonctionnement des
[ __ ] parce qu'il n'ya pas ici qui se
demandent si tf1 aux caisses ou pas les
recettes publicitaires des [ __ ] vous
expliquer comment ça marche je vous ai
fait un petit tableau chacun samaria un
appel d'offres par les restos du coeur
qui donne environ
les sommes varient selon les années 3
millions d'euros j'ai un confort il a
déjà ses classements des demandes
les restos du coeur vous donne 3
millions d'euros pour le concert des 2e
partie sort et c'est tf1 achète le
spectacle 3 millions d'euros 3 environ
ya pas que le spectacle est 2e à val de
reuil donne pas les recettes encore il
ils ont le spectacle 3 voilà exactement
stephen st un producteur qui est
bénévole d'accord tous bénévolement qui
fait juste la direction artistique et
producteur que j'aime beaucoup les voilà
les artistes sont des bénévoles il ya
juste les équipes techniques qui sont
rémunérés mais c'est normal s'il ya des
gens qui n'arrêtent toute l'année sur
les [ __ ] et enfin en caisse les
recettes publicitaires mais ça ne comble
pas les 3 millions d'euros et gagne
environ 1 ou 2 millions d'euros donc
personne ne gagne de l'argent avec les
[ __ ] parce que donc tf1 quand même y
y ils perdent 1 millions d'euros
oui voilà ils ont grèce mais ils perdent
en fait donc c'est comme si on faisait
ça de manière bénévole un peu d'accord
oui personne pas même les pertes rob
maver donne de l'argent bien sûr
dans la soirée des enfants et c'est rien
de le dire bravo mme guissé d'opérations
de communication pour tf1 aussi quand
même hein il récupère en images les
restos du cce a cartonné sur mais bon
s'ils osaient les auraient défoncé y
perdre un million d'euros il faut le
dire mais c'est un dvd prennent rien il
faut le dvd présent
chaque fois qu'elle existe la forêt du
jour bravo tf1 vous après c'est vrai que
ça fait ça fait même si ça fait un
carton d'audience
ils n'arrivent pas à à rentabiliser
hyper d'un milieu plus qu'ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est le plus gros des
recettes des restos du coeur c'est bien
la vente du show du spectacle plus les
cds la vente des cd des valeurs vous n'y
a pas de mauvaise ambiance au sens fort
et non moi je suis chaque année je vous
écoute et là bas est ce qui fait qu
outre des interviews la basse et des
interviews tous les artistes pour qui
pour la radio à l'époque c'était une
radio web radio ouais jamais diffusé une
scène interne en mes frères dont le
patron l'abri des aléas vous avez une
sorte de placement j'avais une sorte de
passe droit à l'époque avec anne
marcassus les gens pourquoi suis-je
encore convalescent leurs concerts qui
sont tranquilles volta kozak tu sais pas
oui l'artiste venait 6 avait envie de
venir sont venues non
cela dit le spectacle est magnifique
essai par des artistes il ya beaucoup de
boulot il faut savoir que tous les soirs
qui se pare d'or il ya beaucoup de
boulot il se donne beaucoup mais il est
vrai qu'il ya quelques tensions
dirais-je quand certains artistes ne
venait que pour l'enregistrement qui
était le samedi et le dimanche ça
servait pas mal voilà l'autre - y'a pas
de mauvaise ambiance bien voilà alors
oui et kelly qui voulait lui dire
l'accepter comme tous les rassemblements
où il ya des gens qui ont un petit peu
des ego surdimensionnés simplement
nationale c'est la guerre c'est
difficile de gym des artistes comme ça
sur une tournée surtout quand il faut se
cognent à une représentation
après ça fait quand même des années
qu'on parle des mauvaises ans de
mauvaise ambiance oui de mauvaise
ambiance
donc ya pas de fumée sans feu bien sûr
qu'il ya une super mauvaise ambiance et
merci oui vous avez des langues se sont
déliées oui avec les artistes eux-mêmes
là encore il ya le mois dernier que ses
liane foly qui a dit que l'ambiance dans
les coulisses c'était pas la petite
maison dans la prairie
patricia kaas qui avait dit oui ça joue
des coudes et à l'ego de certains toiut
pourquoi lui va chanter cette chanson
est pourquoi il portait le cos que je
vous le dis il paraît que c'est la
guerre
chanter les chansons les costumes
patricia kaas l'avait dit thomas dutronc
il avait dit je ne veux plus y
participer parce qu'effectivement les
gêne les gens viennent juste pour
revenir et passer à la télé n'a su
encore ça joue des coudes et là encore
amel bent a mais amel bent dans les
coulisses il y à des tensions
yann robin pierre palmade mais c'est
normal tout ça attaque simulée puis me
permettre en fait on s'en fout mais
complètement m'enfuir sûr que casey
gulati les crêpages de chignons peu ta
chanson je veux pas ta chanson je veux
ta perruque je pas ta perruque sa cause
mon compte mais thomas dutronc il ya
vianney et tout va bien il ya d abord
des douilles à des sortants ya la
nouvelle génération il ya le site
génération et à ceux qui sont
nostalgiques ou mélancoliques ou
d'anciens qu'il ya plus jeune jane wyman
ça mais peu importe j'ai l'impression
que ça cartonne
et on a vraiment besoin de lui
malheureusement je dois dire de plus en
plus de repas pour les [ __ ] et ses
accès ça qui compte
c'est vrai isabelle alors oui on en
parle effectivement parce qu'elle est en
effet les partenaires plus mais on
continue à le traiter les auteurs il
s'en va il fallait qu'ils soient au plus
exposés des trois ans qu'on l'a plus
mais on le traite régulièrement mais
dont on en parle parce qu'elle en a
parlé elle a parfaitement raison de dire
ce qu'elle a dit moyenne- zenden koné g
je vous allez assister aux répétitions
pour vsd des [ __ ] et moi j'avais été
frappé par sa effectivement ce qu'ils
disent je veux vendre plus d'albums je
venais il ya des succès comme dans la
vraie vie de sortie vous pensez y voit
moins que c'est nécessaire c'est sûr
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui veut
m'interviewer la mise
savez vous quel journal on va donner par
sa maman merci oui mais ce genre de
sortie vous pensez franchement que c'est
utile et que les gens ils vont dire oh
là là ils sont pas bien oh là là ils
sont prétentieux oh là là ils sont
jaloux donc du coup on va pas acheter le
cd parce que ça va alors qu'ils histoire
d'ego de stars et tout ça mais du coup
je trouve que c'est contreproductif et
de bresse l'affairé non seulement je
saurai si elle répond à une question
cela devrait dire si on le fait on
valoir
il ya même s'il vous plaît donnez lui un
bras j'ai vu qu'à quai oui ça va venir
au nom de la cause elle ne devrait pas
dire ce qu'elle pense et on va voir ce
qu'on pense étaient les spectateurs
payent des impôts
j'ai des revenants je pense que à
l'époque avait des appuis oui je peux
vous dire que depuis que goldman n'est
plus à la tête des [ __ ] c'est lui
était le vrai premier apprendre les
chansons les moins les moins fortes à
prendre les délais des vivants les plus
ridicules et que depuis qu'il n'est plus
là effectivement c'est plus compliqué
mais je rejoins effectivement géraldine
c'est pas normal
et j'aime beaucoup et j'aime beaucoup
élèves mais elle devrait pas d'amour non
mais ça n'a pas d'intérêt parce que le
seul intérêt de ce spectacle c'est
évidemment que ça fonctionne et des gens
c'est normal elle s'est égarée à 25%
voilà les gens le sont un jour le sens
que les gens du lycée ce père qui les
gens du golfe et les gens d'ici
non